terrorists want to disrupt normality if  you want to do something about it you  carry on being normal do what you do  we've known it for a long time since 911  you know and nobody ever fought them not  really you know it is no truth from  England or America or France on the  ground in Syria jada and I were up all  night you know that was the subject of  our conversation you know as our hearts  and our prayers go out to you and you  know all the families involved and you  know what what to do where does it in  how does it stop what do you do well I  can repay its a tragedy and my heart  goes out to the victims and their  families like it's a horrific event that  we can we can rise up from that horror  and try to find something to do about it  in a constructive binding way between us  and others there's something we can gain  from this event we shouldn't lose sight  of that and our anger and now I'm paying  about